historically most of the people who came
to cities were far more concerned with
survival than with urban amenities the
Irish who came to Boston fleeing the
potato famine the Russians who came to
New York to escape the pogroms and the
african-americans who came to Chicago to
escape the Jim Crow South they weren't
looking for cooler art museums or
Mediterranean climates or really good
cappuccino they wanted safety at a
decent living
most urban migrants in the developing
world want the same things today but in
the wealthy world today
urban success is increasingly driven by
consumption not production I don't mean
that cities don't need jobs every
successful city needs a robust economic
engine but I do mean that wealthier
better educated people are increasingly
willing to base their moving decisions
based on quality of life even if it
means taking a pay cut Los Angeles in
Miami our consumer cities and climate
provided these places with their
original appeal but people also seem to
be willing to accept lower real wages to
experience the excitement of New York
London's sky-high real estate prices are
also a sign of its consumer appeal I
have often argued that the best economic
development strategy is to attract and
train smart people and then get out of
their way that may be too simplistic of
you but it does emphasize that improving
a city's quality of life is actually an
economic development strategy moreover
since quality of life increases property
values cities seeking more revenue have
an added incentive to improve their
urban amenities but what attributes make
cities particularly attractive places to
live climate is clearly important
January temperature is the single best
predictor of metropolitan area growth
during the 20th century in the u.s. but
city governments can't do much about the
weather they can do something about the
man-made aspects of urban life but what
should they focus on are people looking
for fun hip eateries cool clubs art
galleries or are they seeking more basic
amenities like safe streets and short
commutes should cities be deregulating
food trucks and bars or should they be
regulating buildings to preserve
historic neighborhoods in this section
we're going to ask why amenities have
become a more important part of urban
success and what cities can do to
enhance those amenities
you